the greatest of all time here we go the
Epic Trilogy fight for the first time
ever Demetrius Johnson defends the one
flyweight World Championship in the USA
one fight night ten Johnson versus
Marias 3 on Prime video
now Brandon
six four
uh let's get some fights though man
because this weekend uh you got four of
the best I mean probably four of the
best the very best 135ers competing you
have one Championship with Mighty Mouse
Marias in the rubber match and then you
got Al Joe and Henry sahuto uh I mean
you're a hardcore so you can watch both
is there one you're more excited for
oh
I have to yeah they're both pretty great
honestly
um you know I think for work I have to
devote more attention to the UFC side
but the but the one Championship product
I gotta say like I
I think that one is the only at this at
this stage right now and this could
change tomorrow but as we're speaking at
this moment I'm I firmly believe that
one is the only true alternative for MMA
fans to the UFC there's obviously good
Fighters and good fights at Bellator
there's good Fighters and good fights of
pfl but one is a very different product
they're in Colorado for folks who don't
know this is a big a big deal the UFC
has pledged to not go back to Colorado
because their commission decided to
accept a different rule set the one that
one uses which has a lot of differences
like me so that of a ground opponent
judging a fight as a whole you name it
um and I actually really like the way
that they do judging I like the open
rule set so you know the Commission in
Colorado took a bit of a gamble with
with doing this and I think MMA fans
should be you know supportive of any
kind of promoter in that particular
sense trying to do something different
in that regard but to with respect to
the point of the fight itself
um I think for me if we look at the
second fight we're asking what might be
different in the third one man I tell
you what and it's something you're very
familiar with Brendan elevation the
elevation in Denver is a [__]
because in the second fight between DJ
and Marias you know DJ spent the the in
the words of Rich Franklin he spent the
bulk of the first two rounds on his back
that absolutely happened but then he
began to fade a little bit in the third
and then he obviously got stopped in the
fourth DJ really put it on him man if
you're not used to that altitude and
we'll see if DJ is I think he probably
will find a way to make it work but if
you're not used to it it will cut you in
half and I have a feeling it's going to
play a major role in that outcome agree
to that point that's the reason why the
UFC will never have a heavyweight fight
in Colorado anymore let alone you know
with their issues with the commission
but even when they were going to
Colorado if you remember back in the day
you had Mark hunt Ben Rothwell now I was
backstage when they walked past exhaust
but exhausted so UFC's like no more
heavyweights well how dare you you I
thrived in that air but um uh but yeah
so we had DJ on the show he came to
Colorado he's been there for over two
weeks to get acclimated and he met with
a professional cyclist seeing when's the
best time to do it because obviously you
have to compete in those high elevations
so he's really focused on that he's been
there over two weeks training getting
ready for this now Mariah's I don't know
I don't know I haven't heard
yeah and like all the places I was
looking at where he fought he fought in
Las Vegas which has a little bit of
elevation but not much and then him and
Mariah have both mostly fought in like
Singapore which is basically sea level
or you know what uh places in the
Philippines which are basically sea
level so this is going to be a dramatic
one if he was fading in that fight
trying to hold on to DJ but he also
rocked him a little bit too with like a
head kick in this that's why I like this
fight because it's not like it's tough
it's tough to call because they've both
like neither one like dominate the other
like it could both fights go either way
so this third fight it's not like uh
DJ's gonna mop the floor with him like
no not really yeah if you again if you
only watch the first two rounds of the
second fight you'd be like DJ's in
trouble he begins to turn it a little
bit thereafter so you know if he's in
great cardiovascular conditioning or he
has it rather and Marias doesn't that
will be I mean anybody who's ever been
to Denver or huge knows about the
elevation that will be the determining
Factor but if both guys are up for it
and again I don't know what Maurice has
or hasn't done
um either way they're just a great match
it's a great rivalry and you know I had
this stat that it only applies to UFC
fighters but I'll share with you you may
have seen it and it goes like this
between 125 and 170 as weight classes if
you look at uh UFC fighters over the age
of 35 what's their record in those
weight classes and title fights it's 2
and 28 and those two belong to Tyron
Woodley and in one of those Tyrone
Woodley fights he was fighting a 39 year
old right so age is profoundly unclined
to the lighter weight classes you might
be asking well what is it between 185
and up it's 50 50. so you go from two
and two and 28 to 50 50 basically it's a
dramatic drop down now here's the funny
part about it I don't know how folks
view Demetrius Johnson because to your
point he's a flywave fighter but this is
at 135 because of the way one does their
weight classes and so
um no bansomware at 36 years of age has
ever won a UFC title fight
number one Henry cejudo 36 years of age
we'll see what he does on Saturday also
when DJ Beat Morris in their second
fight he was already 36 by that time do
you count that as part of it no because
it's the UFC stat but you know that's of
that grade that caliber so the really
good ones can Buck the trend but again
who's getting older Maurice is pretty
old too but I think DJ is the slightly
older of the two I'll double check that
yeah I'm not sure how old Marias is but
with and I did bring that stat up to DJ
and DJ was laughing at it you know he's
like yeah but but he did to the point
he's like remember I was 36 when I won
this the second fight yes he's like but
it's not in the UFC so that that's not
including those stats the other
um Mirage is 35. yeah so Mariah's is 35
35 so he's right out of two he's right
there too and those outlets and that's
my same thing not to just jump across
the UFC but that's my same thing with
the Henry pseudo aljo fight when I see
that stat
you know before that stat I was like ah
sahuto's such a beast man yeah you don't
want to bet against the Hutto you see
that stat I'm like
it's not it's not great looking for
sehudo there especially three-year
layoff he's older Al Joe's in his prime
aljo's 33 I mean he's smacking in the
middle of it and um he's taller he's
rangier he fights tall he fights rangy
been acting he has he's been active I
would argue that he's got the best back
control certainly in that division
arguably in the UFC maybe even in MMA DJ
made that point he weaponizes it yeah
because you know DJ and sahuto they've
done a podcast together they train
together and I I asked him who obviously
he's taking sahuto he goes but the issue
is and as I said this to Henry you
cannot let Al Jermaine get on your back
he's special there he said he cannot let
him take your back he goes what's scary
about algeman now because I don't know
when people can give him his respect but
he's found his Lane before he was
fighting even in those Peter John fights
you know we he didn't really know he was
really good because he got there he goes
now he knows now he knows if he gets
your back that's where that's where he's
special and once a fighter knows that
it's trouble he's like so far I really
feel
go ahead sorry sorry I meant to cut you
off Brandon I apologize but like I
really agree with that I really feel
like there was a wild there where you
kind of could tell Sterling was going to
be something and he hit a couple of
roadblocks got that bad knockout loss
for example to Marlon moration you know
some stuff went sideways but
um I feel like his game has not only has
he found his own identity but he
simplified it in a in like a not like in
making it Dumber but in elevating it
like what I mean is dude he just knows
like he him Charles Oliveira these guys
like if you look at for example if you
look at the takedown successful takedown
rate for algeman Sterling it's very low
it's in like a 40 percentage or
something or even 20 percentage sorry is
a effective takedown rate is like
somewhere 24 I mean it's low super low
for a wrestler that's really low that's
his back extremely low yeah but you
might be asking well how can it be so
low and how is this guy the champion the
reason why is because
Sterling and some other guys he's not
alone in this regard but there's a few
guys right now who have uh and you're
seeing it more and more but who have to
this point done a really good job of not
looking for takedowns shooting takedowns
looking for back exposure yes sir that's
it they're just trying to get behind
your elbows and get your hands to the
mat that is it that's all they're trying
to do and then once they create back
exposure it's a it's [__] curtains
for you bro it's curtains for you and
you and I both have a very high opinion
yeah well you're gonna say you and I
both have a very high opinion of Corey
sandhagen but he ran into a buzz saw
that night from the back and I
understand that big time Big Time I love
coin he's you know absolutely adore
Corey but yeah with when DJ brought that
up I'm like yeah that's his special
sauce and he's like and he knows that
and he's Champion he's like it's trouble
man he's like that's why I told Henry
he's gonna shoot you know and he has to
be very careful because it's not even
about the shot it's about the transition
and sojudo knows that he doesn't he
doesn't need to get fully in on that
single leg or double leg he just has to
transition to your back going to get
there he was he's a we've been studying
the tape like he's the best I've ever
seen do it once he gets your back the
way he can maneuver and capitalize on
that he's like it's trouble man yeah
he's definitely his wrist setting on
aljo thank you DJ yeah his his wrist
capture I mean his ability to control
different whether he needs hooks or
whether he needs the body triangle and
then you know how to use I mean he can
just do all different kinds of stuff
from pinning to ground a pound to
whatever else he needs to do but the
other point I want to make though is
you know when I say a stat like that
people automatically think that I'm
telling you that Henry cejudo can't win
that's really not what I'm saying like
if there's anybody who has shown a
competitive capacity to to raise his
game to the moment to the stakes and you
know he was not expected to win the 2008
you know Olympics um you know metal I
don't think anyway he won the whole
thing because he had the [__]
Tournament of his life in 2008 and when
he came back against Mariah's Mirage the
same thing to win the bantamweight gold
what I'm pointing out to you is listen
age at 135 pounds is deeply unforgiving
and I do think because of that and the
inactivity he's got an uphill climb on
the other hand it is it is worth putting
some respect on Henry suhuto's name and
saying if there is one guy who could
Buck a trend and what's a small sample
size there will be exceptions he's that
guy yeah that and just to piggyback on
that again those signs would point to
aljo even though he's a slight dog here
the points with the the all indications
say algae could probably get it done so
once you have seen that stat but you're
dealing with a guy in Henry sahuto and
uh DJ alluded to this as well I said I
would never bet against him because of
here I think as far as mental mental
game goes there's a few outliers he's
one of the all-time outliers it's him DC
Jon Jones DJ's up there and I've never
seen anybody like Henry sahuto who has
that mental fortitude but also the
changes he can make where if his
original game plan isn't going well you
see between rounds he can make
adjustments and figure out at a very
high level to beat world-class guys so
although that stat looked horrible for
Henry sahuto sohudo he's one he's an
outlier it doesn't I I don't agree with
that stat when it comes to Henry studio
if there's anybody who's gonna Buck the
trend like you said attendance with that
with his mental state it's Second To
None man second I mean you're talking
about if you want to argue possibly the
greatest Combat Sports athlete of all
time with their gold medal in the
Olympics two-time divisional champion
UFC comes back wins this I mean Jesus
Christ yeah because you could say well
he got out of the division before it
really matured and I would argue that he
did he you know whatever whatever his
reasons were you know he decided to call
quits and then the division really kind
of grew up in those three years so he's
coming back right into the mouth of the
lion I mean absolutely at a time when I
mean is anyone going to argue
bantamweight isn't popping right now oh
it's like yeah I think it's amazing to
the point you raised like even in over a
one one's main event is man some way and
it's [__] sick you know what I mean
like that there's just so much talent
there
um but I also just think it's also worth
saying in addition to all the great
things we're saying about Henry sahuto I
have a sneaking suspicion that
um even if he wins they might deny it to
him
Sterling and his championship rung has
been met with some questions like
dilshaw's arm falling out of his socket
didn't really tell you anything about
how that fight was going to go because
he was so injured like you got nothing
out of it and then and then the first
yawn fight you know that wasn't going
his way before it all came to a
conclusion but of course he he looked
really good in the second fight I just
mean to say that there are certain
people that aren't sold on Al Jermaine
Sterling and I don't know if a win on
Saturday fully converts everybody that's
why I was going it was a nice win say
again that that's why I was gonna hate
to interrupt you brother sorry man
even if aljo beats suhudo the lack of
respect that aljo gets so if he beats
ahuto the narrative I guarantee he's
gonna be I said who was older man look
at the stat he's older he's 36
three-year layoff what's next it does
for alto this is don't get me wrong he
wants to win but it's a no win for him
really because the people have that that
escape X
it's like oh you [__] man I think I
think that there's a I think that
um I agree in one sense which is
you know because of the age because of
the time off you'll be like ah you got
you got whatever version of Henry sahuto
this is an aged version of he's already
on YouTube and he's already doing his
he's already pivoted you know yep on the
other hand I think if he goes in there
and has a tough fight but perseveres
like to the point you raised about
sahuto you go to the Mirage fight he was
getting his legs chewed up in the first
rounds and then he took it away in the
second round and then [__] put it on
him in the third you can see him take
pieces of the game away from him in real
time if Sterling can muster an effort
like that to your point there's gonna be
people who dismiss it but I wonder if he
might be able to get a little bit more
respect if he can turn in a clear
dominant forward
uh like aggressive smart even
challenging uh effort I wonder what that
could do for him if it's like a back and
forth you know we see him in a little
bit of trouble he's down two rounds come
comes back puts it on him gets a late
finish maybe but if he goes out there
and head kicks him in 15 seconds we're
like that's gonna do nothing for aljo
gonna be a great highlight being like oh
dude you kick an old guy's head off
and if he just takes his back for three
or four rounds and then either submit
some legs
yeah that doesn't do much for him he's
got a really he's got to do something
memorable you know it also gets
interesting if you're the UFC because if
aljo does win
then marab and aljo refuse to fight each
other so then you do sugar Sean probably
I guess you know it gets a little tricky
there
so volkanovsky another guy's got a
YouTube channel uh believes that that
um the winner here no matter what is
going to call him out and I think he's
right so you know so who knows who has
been wanting the volcanovsky fight for a
while obviously volcanovsky's got Yaya
Rodriguez at UFC 290
um I don't know if he'll get it again it
depends on a lot of factors Sterling I
think the cut to 135 he does it and he's
you know dice to the socks but
I don't know how much longer he can keep
that up I think he actually I think if
he wins here he has indicated that
moving up is a real possibility for him
as well so I think you might get someone
who just potentially here's the thing
they don't want to give up the title and
then just go to 140 and then not have
the belt to make the most amount of
money for rev so they want to use it to
Parlay a title shot can they get one at
maybe sahudo could yeah I don't know if
this is going to give Sterling that
fight yeah uh aljo's trading partners uh
Steamroller great guy he's fighting on
the card and he was like he was like
yeah alja's gonna go up so there's a
there's a they don't need to fight each
other because I told him I said don't
get me wrong man I love that you guys
are brothers and you've gone through
camp together and you refuse to fight
each other I said but becoming a world
champion is life changing for your
family it's just life-changing there's I
you know the only person I want to fight
is my brother outside that I'm fighting
anybody man to get to that title shot
you know so I said I understand it but
then the day it's about providing for
your family and then um Mike Steamroller
goes it's not all just about belts and
Money Man sometimes it's more about like
our friendships and he's like and I do
think we just gotta wait it's too early
he goes because I think aljo he you know
he's talked about he can go up a weight
class and that leaves it open for murab
so they don't need to fight man I was
like Fair Point that's what you guys
want to do fair point because marob's a
[__] [__] yeah Jesus I
mean a nightmare to fight a guy who
it's impossible for him to be tired
yeah just terrifying terrifying you know
against Jana what he shot how many times
some [__] like that nuts
like you know I wasn't a pro athlete
like you but as heavyweights like what
marab does in terms of volume is even
for Kane Velasquez incomprehensible oh
no incomprehensible yeah
my producer chin has skeptical hip wise
after that fight I'm like dude how about
marob's card is like pretty interesting
like how dare you how dare you
it's just oh that's hilarious yeah it's
just unheard of man it's unheard of uh
but I can't wait for it and then it's
weird because usually the summer time's
pop in for the UFC like you know you
have the big July car and all that stuff
it just it might it might be in a hater
here but there's nothing like
I'm not that excited about anything
right now right because the Francis
which I want to talk to you about
Francis is left so we're not getting Jon
Jones Francis we're supposed to get John
Stipe that looks like it's gonna be in
November uh maybe Izzy comes back
they're kind of dangling uh uh you know
hamzat coming back a little bit there
but there hasn't been any like big
Blockbuster for the summer announcement
when usually they come with the the
vengeance
yeah they have uh this is something I've
heard from casual fans I mean I'm so in
the weeds I almost don't even feel it
sometimes yeah I know but something I've
heard from casual fans is that you know
UFC has a bit of a star power problem
right now right
um Conor is back in orbit but we don't
have them signed up for anything we
think we're gonna get him this year but
there's nothing on to your point nothing
on the docket right also if you saw the
testing pool
like yeah I'll look I mean that I mean
does anyone think that's actually a
really slow down Conor like just a bunch
of nonsense but yeah um he's you know to
his point the champion does what the
[__] he wants he's right yeah I like it
I just get just get him in there I don't
give a [__] he's juice I mean does
anybody I mean who's who's the person
like no no we can't make that Chandler
fight until he's waited six months of
drugs even Chandler goes in here
Chandler goes I don't give a [__] man
just haven't passed like two tests and
he's good to go let's go I mean who
gives a [__] but okay he's not on the
docket to the sport no uh to your point
also Francis not on the docket because
he's not there anymore they are trying
to do obviously what they were for a
time they were trying to do I should say
Jones versus Stipe for international
fight week they couldn't so it looks
like they're gonna punt to to November
potentially to get that fight done but
again that's not confirmed that's just
kind of the rumor mill and so you're
like well what else are we doing out
there obviously we have the Leon Edwards
uh fight with Colby Covington that's
fine but that's not a blockbuster they
just don't have any they have they've
got a lot of actually like really good
fights like for example great stable
yeah I mean they got all the talent the
volkanovsky versus Jerry Rodriguez fight
is amazing love that fight but it's not
a huge pay-per-view draw it's impactful
it's important it's great I'm not
talking bad about it as a fight under
any circumstances I'm just asking what
is it's real box office potential it's
not significant
um and so for that reason it's kind of
what you're talking about is a little
bit of malaise happening where between
these Apex cards that just feel like
nothing and then the lack of big fights
on the docket there's good stuff there's
nothing like really eyebrow raising you
know yeah there's nothing there that's
my only Point like usually they they
break out these big Blockbuster fights
and there's just nothing that I'm like
oh circling you know that even casual is
like oh because I'll be able to dictate
how something's going a little bit
obviously we're in the weeds here but if
I'm at Starbucks there's a big fight
I'll be waiting for my drink people come
up dude who you taking you know what if
it's Jones Joan Sarah God is probably
the last one any Conor fight I always
get a million questions about Connor
Jones Sarah gone people like dude how's
Jones gonna do against this guy my
easiest fight of his life no you're
crazy but that's and that was casuals
but there hasn't been anything like that
for a while so I'm just wondering what
they're gonna do and then you hear you
know Jon Jones to interview with the
Australian uh Fox Sports Outlet he
actually referenced you and you made a
great point for for and thank God to
give you your credit but with with John
too you know he's talking about maybe
one left he goes if Francis came back
great and they're like yeah what about
Sergey Pavlich you know and he's like
I'm good you think that the guy it
wouldn't do any numbers it doesn't make
sense for me to risk my career and
everything to fight this giant rush and
nobody knows about he's like so yeah
it's deep eight could be my last one he
was in it it actually sounds like he's
at peace with it too because he's like
you know all I got to do is you stay on
the straight and Air 0 to November fight
at Mass Square Garden I live the rest of
my life undefeated world champion that
sounds good to me because I want to
spend more time at home and they're like
oh well a Francis fight would get you
out out of bed and he goes yeah but that
doesn't look like it's gonna happen so
I was shocked that he had seen what I
had said I couldn't believe it but okay
neither here nor there to your point
yeah dude you're the hot chick in high
school that doesn't know she's hot yeah
no yeah you're that you're that girl
dude after the 214 debacle The presser
where he Dunked On Me
I just
that was a weird moment in my career
because
when he dunked on you what exactly
happened don't you remember because so
so what had happened was I had so okay
let's back up a couple steps the last
time I think I had seen him
sorry I covered UFC 197 he was supposed
to fight Cormier then I believe but it
got messed up and he ended up fighting
or he was supposed to fight whoever and
he ended up fighting OSP and it was a
not that great of a fight rough fight
yeah then he was supposed to headline
UFC 200 and that whole [__] thing
blew up remember that yeah Nightmare and
uh and then he had subsequent drug
testing issues and all kinds of stuff so
I hadn't seen him basically since UFC
200 when he had all this other
ridiculous Fallout and then he did the
214 press conference and I asked him so
I think he had just turned like 30 or
maybe he was close to 31 he was finally
over the 20 year old hump and here's why
I asked this question I had a bunch of
friends who in their 20s they were kind
of [__] ups like arrested for DUI or
just doing some dumb [__] immature [__]
but they kind of figured it out like
some of them became attorneys and
they're normal but in mine um got
commissioned in the United States Army
as an officer and it does really well
like so I've seen people do dumb [__]
and then turn it around at 30. so I kind
of asked him to reflect on his 20s and
like you know what he had kind of
considered about it and he just goes I'm
not going to answer because I don't like
you and then it just ended up being like
this all-time meme worthy thing which I
I get you can't fight the internet it is
what it is so it's just weird that he
seen like some [__] you know what I mean
like you're just like why what okay but
you're undeniable dude you're undeniable
and it's such a good point too it's such
a good point too you know
but that's the thing you're raising it's
like I honestly think fight to fight
maybe the steepe fight is really great
maybe it's possible but you know Sipe is
in his 40s now too it's like he's kind
of old and this is probably his last
Runner maybe he's got two more or
something but I would say he definitely
is checked out right right okay so you
could make a case that the pavlovich
fight is a better fight just on pure
hardcore fight terms it's not it's not
it's not guaranteed like again John
could take him down and whip his ass in
which case it's not all that great I'm
just simply pointing out
exactly there is plenty of natural fight
Intrigue in seeing John fight Sergey
pavlovich but from a marketing
standpoint I don't know what the [__] it
gets you
um and people were saying oh do huge on
pay-per-view his Q rating here probably
which is very low he just fought in the
[__] Apex like he doesn't have a
whole lot of uh of of a fan base built
here in Russia their ufcs are not sold
on pay-per-view it's part of your basic
cable package over there so that
wouldn't do you any good and a hello he
can knock your [__] head into the
beliefs with his power and what are you
going to get from the pay-per-view sales
which are tied to your pay right the
more you sell the more you make why the
[__] would you take that fight if you
don't have to no right it's such a good
point it makes zero sense for John he's
and you look at his resume too he's like
it just doesn't make any sense he's like
literally it's going to be steepe that
you know that hopefully that goes well
and then it he goes maybe I'd entertain
the Sergey fight if the UFC stepped up
in money and just gave me a guarantee
because we know it's not I can do well
and pay for you he's like just makes no
sense because he's a talented dude he's
a one-trick pony which I I you know
obviously it's John Being John and
fighter stock [__] I wouldn't call
Sergey a one-trick pony his wrestling
wrestling background he's no punk like
if you saw when Curtis blade shot in
that double egg talking about you know
National Champion Juco National Champion
so is John like Juco Nest Champions No
Joke Man Curtis is a Powerhouse has the
record for takedowns his heavyweight
like he's no joke when Curtis shot for
that double leg he was like holy [__]
that's not snowflake like that sergey's
hips were nutsos dude now I'm not saying
John can't take him down talking about
an outlier different you know and
Jonathan do blast doubles really he'll
do the single leg and the chain
wrestling and against the fence second
to none I'm just saying if you're going
there it's not like Cyril God where you
can just you know do his thing and treat
him like a toddler and get him in a
[__] neck crank and tap him out for
World title it's not that it'd be a it's
a tough fight dude his I would argue his
toughest fight at heavyweight yes
currently among UFC heavyweights I would
actually agree again hard to know
exactly what Stipe is going to give but
I would agree that pavlovich is a
[__] he's a he's a a hammer someone
who I think is Russian was telling me
that uh pavlovich wrestled competitively
all the way through age 18. correct um I
think Greco-Roman more than freestyle
but nevertheless like he's he's not
unaccustomed to a wrestling mat by any
stretch the imagination so you add that
to the fact that he's got the same reach
as John or like right around it uh and
he can obviously you know decapitate you
with power it's a cool fight but if
you're fighting in the [__] Apex dude
like you're not building a brand doing
that you're not building a brand doing
that and this is what's a shame you know
to jump into the Francis this how great
of a fight would Francis Sergey be
oh that would be so much fun so much
take my money take my money like there's
so much for Francis in the UFC with you
know Sergey and you got John there and
like he rides off in the sunset doesn't
have an agent you know and then I was
like okay was he gonna sign with one
Championship you know I'm a huge fan of
one championship and chatri absolutely
adore I think he's the smartest guy in
the fight game especially when it goes
as far as CEOs of companies like he's
brilliant Harvard educated loves martial
arts and uh he was on my show finding
the kid last week and afterwards we were
talking about Francis and he goes I'm
actually leaving here to go meet with
Francis in La I'm like oh I hope you get
it done he's like no we can pay him like
we do man we're willing to you know uh
let him box and do his thing so
hopefully he gets done I'm like oh
that'd be great but he he said one one
caveat there is if you look at the
heavyweight champion uh in pf I'm sorry
in one Championship the guy's no joke
like Francis is gonna struggle with that
guy like that's not an easy fight for
him you know he's like so if we sign for
all this money it's a risk on our end
too because it's not like he has he's a
walk in the park over here and also when
it comes to boxing the guy he's talking
about boxing you know so you could look
at a 0-2 start we're paying all this
money so it's a risk for both parties
obviously didn't end up working out
um I think chair alluded to this that
he's going to sign with uh pfl
yeah have you heard that he's inside
with pfl for is it 20 mil
I don't know the number of figures I've
heard are different but everything I'm
hearing is that that is uh not done but
probably imminent and what he meant when
Francis met with chatri he was saying
like the offer has to be so good because
I kind of have a verbal agreement with
pfl basically he didn't say pflia allude
to who it was but you say I have an
offer I'm surprised that he didn't go
with one Championship because pfl
who's he gonna fight what are you gonna
do like what do we do have a different
perspective on this than you oh I loved
it it was moving my part ways here a
little bit but Luke that's why I love
like I have nobody to verbally spar with
over MMA I'm like producers and then I'm
just shooting from the [__] hip I'm
like man can somebody argue with me a
little bit yeah I'll argue a little bit
with you now I want to be clear remember
what I said previously because we got
this one card on Friday it's a Wednesday
debut in the United States I applaud the
Colorado commission and I want to I want
to make sure folks know where my
what My Views are so that it oh you're
just hating hear me out one more time I
believe as it stands one is the only
genuine alternative to the UFC in terms
of being like a a genuinely uh excellent
but also meaningfully different product
with the four ounce Muay Thai and all
that stuff I love what they have
Grapplers too like the ruatola brothers
go in there and just [__] deliver for
them every time she is competing on uh
Friday too he's a savant exactly he's an
absolute he looks like a dork but he'll
tear your knees to Pieces trust me
trains Mark Zuckerberg for God's sakes
all right so you get the idea right like
I like their products I have not had
yeah I have not had a great time
um
I have not had a very productive time
trying to Foster any kind of
professional relationship with jatri and
I would solely blame him for that
um oh really I can tell you a little bit
of stuff yeah I can say a little stuff
off the air but it ain't on me it ain't
on me I can my conscience is clear about
that but more to the point here's why I
just think one is a bad fit for for
Francis now it's partly what you said I
do agree with so they've got an upcoming
heavyweight title unification between
our Argent Buller and then uh Anatoly
malikin for folks who don't know who
Anatoly malikin is you're probably about
to find out he is a [__] machine gun
Savage he is this Russian dude who
already has by the way the interim
heavyweight title because Buller had
some contract to speed they're not going
to fight but that's been on ice for a
little while and then he went down to
light heavily because he's like a really
Nimble heavyweight and beat renier de
Ritter to get their light heavyweight
title and did it like with ease I mean
he beat the shutdown like butter yeah
beat the [__] up like it was nothing and
that dude is [__] great he's really
good already so and it's only malikin to
me is maybe one of the most interesting
Fighters not in UFC independent of
weight class independent of organization
right he's just that good he's just a
little undersized right for for heavy
weight was he 27 yeah yeah he's more
like a six one he if MMA had Cruiser
weight he'd be right there he's
something like that he's the king of the
cruiserweight yeah right he would
absolutely demolish people so and again
we'll see what happens with him but past
those two guys they don't really have
anyone for him and there's a bigger
problem than just that beyond that you
would have to if you're gonna sign
Francis you need to be able to sign
francis's peers too you have to be able
to sign anyone else who could free
themselves from contract to put
themselves in a position to make you
guys money for a fight like you think
about guys who left UFC or any other
organization to go fight fate or in
Pride he was an attraction that pulled
in that regard so if you're going to do
that you gotta it's not just signing
Francis assigning Francis and
understanding that there's going to have
to be a greater roster in play now to
the point that you raise like who's that
gonna be I don't know the answer to that
but there is an interesting wrinkle to
the story namely uh people of other
people have said this and I looked into
it and I when I first heard this I was
like this can't be true and then I
checked with some folks who would 100
know
pfl is trying to buy Bellator that
actually is a real thing now the the
problem is we don't know if Bellator is
going to be sold in its entirety we
don't know if it's going to be sold a
stake we don't know if it's a minority
share a majority share there's a lot of
different ways this could go but like
zoom out for a second if you're the pfl
one thing they've been very good at
um is raising money if they're going to
sign Francis it would actually make all
the sense in the world to try and buy a
Bellator where now you have access to
Ryan Bader now you have access to a
potential series of other heavyweight
opponents how exciting all that is to
you at this moment I don't know that's
my point create oh boy hold on let me
finish let's say that they get Francis
let's say that they get I know it's a
long-winded point so I apologize but no
please let's say that they get Francis
and they're able to buy a controlling
share of Bellator and let's say merge
organizations you don't exactly buy the
world in terms of bringing them over for
heavyweight fights for Francis on
pay-per-view but now now you have
created a very clear destination for any
free agent it is only one place you're
going to go to for heavyweight four
heavyweight at that point now these are
a lot of ifs but that's to me what is
happening behind the scenes is pfl is
pushing all their chips in the middle
and saying let's go be the real
unequivocal number two in the sport
we'll see if they can do it no it's a
great point it's a great Point Miley
caveat there is there's a lot of if so
if if pfl let's say for a sake of
argument they get all Bellator they
absorb all the roster kind of like
Strike Force UFC right so they they take
all of it in so you have the entire
heavyweight division uh from Bellator on
pfl
that's not enough right so you have
right you have the Ryan Bader fight how
many pay-per-views that does not a ton
you're not getting your money's worth
you're not getting your money back for
your business uh who else you got you
got Congo
um you can do Congo there's a potential
way to you could maybe lure Fedor out of
retirement I doubt that they do but
um
JDS I think you could get I think JDS is
available again no one you could make
serious money on pay-per-view no there's
nothing there so then you have to hope
that by putting all those eggs in that
basket you become a destination for
other fighters to come to fight that's
right Francis is what you're banking on
but with with one Championship I feel
like they have the means they have the
money to do that
um it's a risk either way I think for
Francis the home run
a little bit of this has been a disaster
because he doesn't have representation
and trust me I'm a guy who I always
believe I invest in myself I'll
negotiate myself it's exhausting there's
a reason they get percentages it's
exhausting and you're not getting the
best deal even even little old me has a
guy who negotiates on my behalf you know
what I mean like I get it I get it I
tried it for a while and it was a
nightmare but um kudos to the guys that
do and they go well I got this money I'm
like trust me you would have got more
money with an agent because that's what
they do for a living but with Francis I
think at the end of the day when we look
back on this let's say he signs with pfl
and they exhort Bellator
no matter what Francis decides to do if
that boxing fight doesn't come to
fruition if you don't get a Wilder a
fury or Joshua I think it's been a a
mistake and I love Francis love Francis
great guy he's been on the show many
times I just think this whole kind of uh
experiment of representing yourself and
not signing with a major promotion and
not if he doesn't get that big boxing
payday this has been a disaster man
because what what has he missed out on
if if you didn't get boxing okay then
you should have stayed with the UFC you
have Jon Jones you have Sergey there you
have the biggest organization in the
world and the marketing behind it dude
and they offered you the biggest
contract whatever this means in UFC
heavyweight history
there's no way this that we can take
this as a W for Francis if the boxing
doesn't come for to fruition
I
okay so let's let's pause a world where
he doesn't get the big boxing fight
certainly I would agree that would be
a big hit I mean there's just no denying
the amount of money a fight he could
make with let's say Deontay Wilder or
something yeah we're talking what 25 mil
each of those guys probably more you
know for Deontay
um to the point of Jon Jones remember
Jon Jones wanted Deontay Wilder money
right so yeah yeah
um so you know Deontay Wilder makes good
makes good money folks he makes yeah he
makes great cash so yeah insane money if
you don't have that there is a big
question about what the what what did
you really get from it but I'm going to
caution on two levels one we've just not
seen the deal that he has again
allegedly or about to sign with bfl I
want to see what the terms are before I
make any kind of broad declaration about
whether it was worth it because there
could be any number of things that they
structure that could make that
interesting or not or it could be a
complete disaster too that's the other
part the other thing I think we should
keep in mind here is like again I don't
think it would have been a disaster by
an interesting imagination if if Francis
had signed with one but I think it would
have been a very limited deal in terms
of what was really possible also you got
to remember one does have a lot of
capital they have raised a lot of money
that they have they but okay fair enough
but they are hemorrhaging it at an
alarming rate I mean their level of debt
is enormous so there's that too I doubt
that played a role but something to
think about for the future
um
there's a lot of fake news in the media
in the MMA media in particular like a
lot of fake news I'll give you a great
example right now I work at CBS Sports
and Scott Coker was at Bellator
bellator's owned by the same parent
company Prima I'm not backing on Scott
in fact I'm almost saluting them I mean
that yeah so he got out there and he was
saying you know hey we're involved this
is early on when Nate first left the UFC
he's like hey we're involved in the Nate
Diaz sweepstakes and then it turned out
that uh both I heard this and I think
Ariel reported it later that like
Bellator didn't even have a conversation
with Nate Diaz like it was never even
happened but he said it and the media
just reproduced it because Scott knows
that if I because he's a powerful figure
if he just says something yep the media
won't verify it at all they'll just
repeat it it will literally happen yeah
I would very much caution anyone and
this was for any promoter any promoter
anywhere at any point boxing MMA
kickboxing you name it
you do not have to take what any
promoter says without verification and
if they've got a track record of
duplicity or otherwise not exactly
sharing the full details you have
frankly an obligation to do that so I'm
not telling you that what chatri said to
you is automatically wrong because I
don't know that but what I also don't
know is the full side of francis's story
what his deal is going to look like and
to me pfl is able to raise much more
money than basically any other entity
outside the UFC
um how long they can stay in business I
don't know the fact that bkfc at day
film had to put up two mortgages to pay
for the last event God bless them but
that's you know that's a very imperiled
Financial State and one does have a lot
of money but they've also got a lot of
debt
um pfl made a lot more sense to me in
terms of a business entity that could
even afford him and then give him the
luxury of what he wants between the
boxing number May contracts so to wrap
that all up
let's just see what his contract looks
like before we declare one thing or the
other agree because the narrative out
now in this you know Chachi told me this
they offered him 20 million guaranteed
in percentage of pay-per-view how true
that is I you know I have no reason not
to believe chatri you know I don't have
the same experience or relationship that
you do with him I always take anything
as much as I love chatri any any
promoters they're promoters you know
Dana says France never fight in the UFC
again you also said women will never
fight in the UFC right so they're
promoting to say the promoters they're
just promoters and also
you know this is where it would help
Francis to have an agent
they can negotiate these things or have
a conversation with the promoters
whoever they're negotiating with because
they know the narrative is going to come
out one chairmanship decide to part ways
with Francis uh agents go hey before
this gets out let's agree how we're
going to handle this in the media but
with France Stone himself he's like ah
no I'm good and then Chacha comes out
nope we offer him this money we don't
align we're out so it's this France is
taking these kind of social media fake
media hits for the past six months just
hit after hit he didn't have an agent I
really agree with that you know I very
much agree the one thing about this
entire process and listen Francis is his
own guy again let's see what he
negotiates in the end I don't know and
you know I didn't love that Lamar
Jackson wasn't out there with an agent
and just representing himself drives me
nuts he did get a good deal he got a
good deal for it people say that though
look at Lamar don't have an agent I get
that and the guy did sign for the most
guaranteed money in the history of uh
NFL quarterbacks he trust me he would
have got a better deal if he had an
agent right right I'm in general I'm
with you and I think that the one part
of this process that I do really
disagree with Francis on is if you
didn't like your old agent fine
you need to get someone to represent
your interests you should not be doing
this yourself it you know the guy who is
is uh what's the saying I'm gonna botch
it but the the man who has
um basically the idea is like if you
represent yourself in court you have a
fool for a client you know yeah yeah
it's kind of like that I just don't yeah
maybe he can make it work we shall see I
I think in general that doesn't serve
your interests in the best way I mean I
I hope it works out for Francis you know
I hope it works out for France another
thing with the pfl we can end on this
also the other thing with the pfl it's
like with that big box and fight out
there you just got to worry about so the
pfl is going to co-promote that with you
is that going to be outside the contract
right you know pfl has never promoted a
major boxing fight in their work with
Bob Airmen these Savages from the boxing
world
it's pfl because pfl is owned under the
same umbrella right in the UFC because
you is it like a sister company DLC they
have a relationship for sure they have
or no there's no there's no ownership
ties between UFC and pfl they obviously
have the same broadcast partner in ESPN
and then to that point top rank the
biggest boxing promoter who's on ESPN
Bob arum runs top ranking He has
expressed interest in there you go in in
France's but like to the point of your
race if you're Francis whether you
negotiated or you know if someone else
could have done it would have been great
there needs to be a clear split like you
need to have an MMA contract and you
need to have a boxing contract where you
work with a boxing promoter [__] all
that like because you can get in the
wheel and take your money otherwise yeah
that's why I'm saying you're getting the
weeds boxing promoters yeah you're just
getting getting the weeds there and you
got to worry about what you can make
like dude like the reality is in boxing
you can just there's here's an easy way
a a sides in boxing rigged the game I'm
not rigging it in terms of the results
but like for pay so I'll give you a
great example like I've covered many
Canelo fights and he is a gentleman and
he does now interviews in English and
yeah he's a [__] fighters fighter
everyone loves Canelo one thing Canelo
does is he like oh I'm gonna make this
part of like uh I'm gonna have I'm gonna
get a check as a fighter and then he's
going to co-promote with you know Eddie
Hearn or whoever with Canelo promotions
like dude what does Canelo promotions do
on fight week yeah nothing nothing but
they get extra money by virtue of being
this a almost technical entity
Jake Paul too same thing no dude no I no
no no I will give credit to Jake Paul
MVP does a lot on fight me most valuable
promotions is this company agree they do
a ton
so so on fight week like whenever I've
covered this fights with Showtime
whatever you think of Jake or anything
else like Showtime broadcasts it but the
people who put the events together
including weigh-ins including pressers
including anything that's all Jake Paul
that's everything you see there is 100
Jake Paul yeah Showtime just shows it to
everyone yeah Jake Paul sets all that up
with his promotional entity so not shots
to him he actually does a lot agree uh
we'll end on this Jake but quick quick
answer I know you got to run brother
Jake Paul Nate Diaz how do you see that
going down and a are you excited for it
are you one of the guys that love this
kind of thing or
I'm happy for Nate Diaz to get a bag me
too I'm happy for ladies to get a bag
he's 38 you know
um
I don't think it goes great for Nate but
I do see a lane where he wins it is
possible about anyone he's fought I
think he's got the best chance I agree
um but but I think Jake's probably gonna
win yeah yeah Fair Point brother well
you're the best man I could talk to you
for seven hours dude we haven't seen
each other in a while but absolute best
man keep crushing it brother and uh I'll
be harassing you to come back on soon
I'm sure
I'm happy to come back on anytime I
appreciate the invite and uh I'm gonna
go eat I'm gonna get some lunch do you
look do you look thin dude you losing
weight
yeah trying but uh you know it's with it
it's hard when you're 43 bro I'm 40 bro
we have the same problem we have the
same [__] problem dude all right
brother stay well man yes sir you too
for the first time ever Demetrius
Johnson defends the one flyweight World
Championship in the USA
[Music]
Johnson versus Marias 3 on Prime video